this video is brought to you by tonight
welcome today we have a Swedish
invention the SodaStream I don't know
how it works that's soda up green tea
my dad would be proud of me
finally no more YouTube I'm a scientist
dad I'm a scientist I don't know how
this works this is the first time you
mr. president oh Jesus Christ it's gonna
[ __ ] honey you sigh down my soda you
want and that's how you make soda
did you see the bubbles that means it
works oh that's good
this [ __ ] is gonna show whoa no stop
god damn it no
the essence of cow but will it soda must
find out Jesus Christ why is it so hard
child can do this so can I less soda
this baby out
I'm scared
[ __ ] sake our car is leaking it's let's
go why Jesus Christ what that is really
not good
well that's the weirdest [ __ ] thing
it's like drinking straight out of cow's
ass
next up we have some polish vodka g2a
gave it to me as a gift is this buck
smelly all right let's listen
does it soda that is the question okay
all right
vodka will it soda let's find out
I've got milk dripping down on it I'm
not gonna another what happened I think
it's a milk
yeah it's good what's this a gift from
the gods a Loutre
let's open this bad boy up this month's
loot crate it's called invasion let's
open it up
Luke Craig's anxious theme xix every
month and next month it's gonna be dead
but let's check this out t-shirt this
this takes me back to when I was young
really like it okay okay go
he loves it
a flashlight the x-files flashlight
which is water resistant and anti-shock
so if I ever get shocked in water I'm
okay
oh it's cool mini space invader thing
that's pretty cool is this from the
Fifth Element
yeah that's a load is it it's a key card
invasion of the mini prints okay so this
is old-school invasion posters that's
that's cool I like this one oh boy what
a great package next month it's gonna be
dead which is in Deadpool Walking Dead
use the link in the description loot
crate Kansai spirits ID code dudes get
10% off your wall I'm glad I have this
specific item finally something to tame
the beast
his face is too tiny to bite it you
already think you're top oh I killed
your father
okay it's time to bring the soda
experiment in boozled and level we have
this we had this let's make some soda
baby
safety first
Christ how does this keep happening
Oh smell that why didn't you do that
with all the cameras today I don't want
to drink this oh my god why does it
smell so bad it smells so bad bean
boozled will its soda no god damn you
piece of [ __ ]
all right as a great man once said if
you want to drink liquid ass don't
oh it's good really like I tried so long
ago at Jesus Christ this technology
cannot reproduce now let's destroy it
check out those crazy calm slash pills
to order your lootcrate now add the code
pewds and you will get a 10% offer and
your support the dumb show why never
lose my deposit bread anything it would
go so crazy